nettoyez bêcher est planté le jardinage
c'est aussi et surtout une affaire
hivernale une période de repos pour la
végétation mais d'activité pour le
jardinier qui prépare le printemps comme
le rappelle ce paysagiste
on va planter les arbustes les arbres
fruitiers etc
en hiver et on se concentrera aux beaux
jours pour planter peut-être les fleurs
les vivaces etc
on aura les arbustes à fleurs précoce
comme les forsythia qui vont être les le
réveil du printemps on a pas mal de
végétaux qui fleurissent en hiver qui
amènent de l'eau d'heure en hiver voilà
donc beaucoup de végétaux en fait ont un
intérêt hivernale ainsi que leurs bois
on peut avoir des bois fluo des couleurs
fluo etc qui réveille les les jours un
peu grise ailleurs parmi les plantes à
privilégier labruyère vivent assez
rustique elle donne une touche de
couleur grâce à ses fleurs blanches rose
pourpre selon les variétés
l'hiver c'est aussi le moment de sortir
les outils pour offrir une nouvelle
coupe à ses protégés là on va faire
juste une petite taille de nettoyage
pour que ça reparte dès les premiers
beaux jours
donc là on va raccourcir toujours en lui
gardant une forme correcte et en
enlevant une bouaka qui a souffert sur
les premiers mois sur les premiers mois
de jeûne voilà on taille pas trop court
parce que on sait jamais en ce mois de
février on peut encore avoir dû déjà
l'important est donc il sera toujours
temps de raccourcir par la suite s'il
boit venait a encore ajouté
en 2015 la france comptait 17 millions
de jardiniers selon une étude menée par
jarre divers et ifop pour créer son
potager ou son jardin d'éden
n'oubliez pas de protéger les pieds de
vos plantes avec du paillage janvier
reste l'un des mois les plus froids de
l'année